en 2014 des archéologues ont découvert à
lavau dans l'aube une tombes princières
du 5e siècle avant notre ère un site
exceptionnel ou sous un tumulus de 40
mètres de diamètre proposer un homme
avec son char un immense chaudron de
bronze de la vaisselle grecque
des bijoux en or et un couteau dans son
fourreau mais que s'est il passé puisque
on réfléchit ici à ce qu'est une
révolution on va s'intéresser à une
révolution perçu comme uniquement
technologique et qui a eu des
répercussions sociales énormes la
métallurgie
je vais vous expliquer en quelques
minutes comment son apparition a très
rapidement divisé nos sociétés
évidemment pas besoin nécessairement de
métal pour se taper sur la gueule le
silex a fait ses preuves chez nos
ancêtres préhistoriques
on constate néanmoins aux 4ème et 3ème
millénaire un changement radical dans
système de production de commerce et
sépultures au moment de la diffusion des
métaux on appelle ces périodes l'âge du
bronze suivie de l'âge du fer mais comme
toutes les innovations techniques
elle se forge tu l'as sur le temps long
depuis le néolithique au proche orient
n'a trouvé les premiers instruments de
cuivre natif à cailhau nout et pezi
traite dargani en turquie en datation
situe entre 7250 et 6750 avant notre ère
en europe il faut attendre le milieu du
cinquième millénaire pour voir les
premiers centre métallurgique
il faut croire que dans certains lieux
lors coule à flots en bulgarie dans la
nécropole de varna on a découvert trois
mille objets précieux pour un total de
six kilos d'or dans les publications
olic l'invention de la métallurgie
aurait permis la naissance d' immense
réseau de distribution de pouvoir
politique fort et de très grandes
inégalités sociales mais c'est un
raccourci
rien de tout cela n'est à proprement
parler n'est avec la métallurgie tout
est plus visible tout s'accentue ça oui
mais on connaissait déjà sa au
néolithique
si on reste sur les réseaux commerciaux
on sait que des marchands de sardaigne
rejoignait régulièrement le continent
pourrait changer de l'obsidienne c'est
une roche d'ailleurs gelé la
l'obsidienne une roche noir translucide
lâchement joly
on sait aussi que dh taillé dans le nord
d'italie ont été acheminés jusqu'en
écosse bref l'invention du métal ne
transforme pas la nature des relations
humaines et leur degré d'intensité
voilà a plus non en vrai ça a changé pas
mal de trucs on ne sait pas précisément
pourquoi ni comment quelques siècles
cette production a connu un essor
considérable
les répercussions sur les sociétés ont
été énormes avec l'apparition d'une
aristocratie forte avec le métal il mecs
sont devenus riches beaucoup plus riches
à varna le site dont je vous parlais
juste avant l'une des tombes renfermer
des pendentifs des perles des céramiques
plaqué or et même des étuis péniens un
total de 4320 éléments en or soit 1518
drame pour une seule personne
comme souvent en archéologie ce qui nous
parvient ce sont les biens des élites
dont on retrouve les instruments et les
parures car et c'est valable pour toutes
les cultures et toutes les époques les
objets de prestige sont des marqueurs
sociaux
ces nouveaux riches sont brusquement de
très grands profits comme jamais on en a
vus auparavant en attirant vers leurs
sites et des artisans bronzier et des
forgerons cette révolution technologique
est à la base des axes commerciaux de
l'europe telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui
mais également des rapports mercantile
moderne il semblerait qu'en inventant la
métallurgie les humains aient inventé le
modèle politique de type chefferie dans
cette logique plus la technique de la
métallurgie s'améliore plus grande et la
pyramide sociale est plus forte sont les
inégalités la distinction entre pauvres
et riches se voit particulièrement dans
le contexte funéraire en france mais le
troisième millénaire avant notre ère des
personnalités de haut rang centralise
des richesses et se combattirent des
tombeaux immense c'est ce qu'on appelle
les tombes princières meilleur témoin de
cette révolution
logés dans un tumulus le mort est
entouré de biens de prestige rares et
exotiques h hallebardes poignard torque
à nos deux oreilles etc etc
parfois d'autres sépultures plus
discrète classés par an et par genre
entouré le tumulus principal les
archéologues voit dans ces pratiques
funéraires le miroir des inégalités
entre individus mais encore une fois les
inégalités existait bien avant il n'y a
pas eu le paradis du chasseur cueilleur
et puis d'un coup la guerre vous l'aurez
compris avec le métal on peut
s'identifier et distingué socialement ce
soit sont vivants ou même dans l'au delà
ce ne sont pas des objets du quotidien
du domestique qui accompagne à présent
les morts mais des armes pour souligner
leur position sociale
mais est ce que cette affirmation sera
toujours
cette question m'est venue quand viviane
expliqué de l'impression 3d devenait une
technologie exploitable par tous et dans
ce contexte on peut se demander si les
âmes échappent à ce système
ça tu vois c'est un fichier qui a été
créé par un américain cody wilson sa
peuple et le gouvernement tintin peut le
bloquer parce que là il a mis une arme
en ligne à disposition donc forcément
gouvernement essaie d'enlever le fichier
mais tu peux pas vraiment confisqué un
fichier comment tu veux faire la seconde
où le gouvernement le prince mais il y
aura forcément une autre personne qui va
le mettre en ligne ça va être la
première fois je pense dans l'histoire
d'humanité où il ya ça qui se passe
parce que par un point marqué au pouvoir
bien que jusqu'à présent pas les armes
les armes en métal c'est vraiment la
propriété des des riches une
aristocratie qui est très riche et qui
peut se permettre que les moyens de se
payer des armes et d'ailleurs c'est
tellement précieux qui s'enterre avec
les mecs ah ouais alors que eux la bombe
à les hanter avec des manettes ses
premiers metal est donc un élément de
ségrégation et de cloisonnement social
entre pauvres et riches
il est aussi entre hommes et femmes même
si on connaît beaucoup de sépulture de
femmes comme la très riche tombe de vix
la maîtrise du nouveau metal et surtout
à l'avantagé des hommes h poignard
outils agricoles permettent d'asseoir
une certaine supériorité masculine
les stèles et statues menhirs nous en
apprennent beaucoup sur les
transformations sociales opéré par
l'avènement de la métallurgie
ces statues menhirs présenta héros un
ancêtre ou un personnage charismatique
et joue le rôle de blason familial
les familles sont symbolisés par leur
poitrine par des accessoires paru les
hommes eux portent des armes d arc des
flèches dh mais surtout des poignards se
sont non des accessoires qui permettent
de déterminer le genre sexe ne figure
jamais sur les représentations
artistiques
un peu comme barbie et ken si on suit
cette logique les femmes sont
déterminées par des caractères
biologiques et naturels que sont les
saints et les hommes par des armes
c'est-à-dire des productions culturelles
alors on peut sans doute pas mettre de
côté la question esthétique parce que
franchement la poitrine
on dira ce qu'on voudra ses canons et
peut-être que c'est tout ce qui compte
est bref ce grand progrès technique a
finalement été un instrument pour
renforcer une forme de domination
celle d
hommes sur les femmes et des riches
surtout les autres pour un archéologue
c'est cette transformation des
structures sociales qui est importante
pas qu'on abatte un arbre avec une hache
en bronze plutôt qu'en faire ça c'est
anecdotique
c'est la fin de cet épisode merci à tous
de l'avoir regardé vous pouvez vous
abonner laisser un commentaire laisser
un pouce bleus et puis n'oubliez pas on
a un discours sur laquelle on peut se
retrouver pour discuter échanger sur
cette série salut à la prochaine
[Musique]